let's cover some theory the cool shop
effect a quick bit of vocabulary
throughout this when we're bringing up
examples we're going to be talking about
the editor and we're going to be using
this title in the abstract and the same
way that we do when we're discussing the
author we're not necessarily talking
about the individual who does the
editing as much as we're talking about
the concept of the person who does the
editing because in reality it might be
several people or it might be one and
here's a link if you want to know more
about that also our examples are going
to be taken mostly from 10 Cloverfield
Lane a 2016 film with pretty solid
editing all around it is stumbling
around isn't helping anything what you
heard earlier was him knocking over a
shelf with a whole week's worth of food
which he's sorry for correct
totally
let's go so let's go a Shaab was a
soviet filmmaker in the early 20th
century but really he was a seer Titian
he made movies but he was more
interested in the ideas of how movies
worked in particular the psychological
mechanics of editing now if you go and
read up on this you're going to see the
word montage a lot so I think this is a
good moment to maybe clear this up the
thing to keep in mind is that this was
literally a century ago the roots of
modern film theory largely originated in
France in the 19-teens so the first
waves of film theory in America England
Germany and the Soviet Union heavily
borrow the French vocabulary French
writers differentiated editing into two
concepts coup pair or cutting the
mechanical process of putting the film
together and monter the creative act of
editing of which the end product is
montage so while modern English Theory
uses the word montage to describe a
specific kind of sequence where a series
of mostly discontinuous Clips are shown
in fairly rapid succession the early use
of the word montage refers to what we
would today simply consider editing this
is important to keep in mind because if
you're reading old theory it's easy to
trick yourself into thinking the
theories only apply to what we call a
montage but really these ideas apply to
all editing so in the early 1920s
Kuleshov is teaching at the Soviet
National Film School and he's telling
his students he's writing that the soul
of cinema is in the Edit it's in the way
that two shots interact in fact he
argues that acting itself can be
completely suborned by editing it is not
the actor that matters it is the cut
more meaning he says it created by the
interaction of two shots than by any
shot in isolation to demonstrate this he
puts together a famous editing exercise
an actor sits and stares at the camera
with a blank expression this shot is
then intercut with a number of other
images war footage a hot meal children
playing and so on the perception on the
part of the audience is that the face
takes on the implications of reaction
the neutral expression looking sad or
hungry or worried in turn following the
war food and child the meaning is
created not from either the a shot where
the
shot it is created from the
juxtaposition of the two because there's
a couple of things going on here versus
the idea of eye line this is another
thing that we address briefly in Suicide
Squad the instinct to follow someone's
eye line that if someone on screen is
looking somewhere and we cut away it is
assumed that the be shot is the thing
that they are looking at even if a and B
aren't factually anywhere near each
other a character looks somewhere in the
a shot we assume the B shot is what they
were looking at the second is the idea
of meaning or what it means when we say
meaning the instinct is to assume that
it's a deeper metaphorical kind of
meaning that we're saying theme and
value are created by the interaction of
two shots and while that is true
metaphor is created by the interaction
between shots it's also a lot more
mundane it's the kind of thing you're
not even thinking about let's look at
that Cloverfield shot again the meaning
that's created is that these two shots
are in the same space the meaning is a
better understanding of the geography of
that space the meaning is this is what
Michele is seeing the very next cut is
to a close-up of the slaughtered pigs
even though this is not contiguous with
Michele's actual field of vision
it is not a literal point of view shot
because human eyes don't have a zoom
function it is emotionally continuous by
cutting from far to close the editor is
saying that this is important they are
highlighting the emotional impact the
sense that a shocking thing seems to
consume our focus then Kuleshov effect
in full force the editor cuts back to
Michele for her reaction a shot be shot
the simple fact that we are even able to
describe this as a reaction shot is owed
to this psychological phenomenon this
forms the logic behind the rules and
dialect of film editing the shot reverse
shot of dialogue the progression from
establishing shots in word to close-up
the preservation of screen direction
through travel and so on because of this
meaning becomes inherent to the sequence
a careful consideration of placement
order and timing is necessary to both
create desired meaning and to avoid
undesired meaning now what do I mean by
undesired meaning well
stakes mostly confusion is a kind of
meaning in the same way that
incomprehensible noise is still an audio
signal this is actually an important
paradigm shift in the way that you look
at editing a bad edit Suicide Squad
isn't generally bad because of some
inherent mechanical failure it's bad
because it creates undesired meaning it
creates confusion when confusion wasn't
intended this car crash is confusing
because it's supposed to be confusing
you're supposed to get disoriented it's
emotionally and narrative ly appropriate
thus the confusion becomes an aesthetic
choice rather than a mistake now one of
the things that I do need to bring up
I've recreated Kuleshov demonstration
here but you're probably thinking to
yourself that it doesn't work nearly as
well as I'm insisting that it does and
there's a couple reasons for that
first is that you as a viewer have grown
up your entire life watching movies in
television
the language of film the language of
continuity editing is very natural to
you you are used to quickly picking up
on visual cues at environment so
discontinuous location is more likely to
trip you up
second is resolution I'm showing you
these images in full-color
high-definition we're cool jobs original
experiment would have looked a lot more
like this
this lower resolution is important
because it taps into another related
idea which is closure now this is a
subject all its own but the core is that
the more iconic or cartoons something is
the easier it is to accept
discontinuities or unrealities now to
wrap this up I do want to throw in some
caveats the edit is the final
interpretive stage in creating a movie
in building its meaning before it is
handed over to the audience and owing to
that position it is so powerful in its
ability to reshape meaning that all the
prior stages writing and performance
reposition themselves to accommodate
things are written and performed with an
eye towards the Edit cool job was being
purposefully dramatic about the
all-consuming power of the edit in
creating the meaning of film the ability
to erase the actor but only a little bit
this quirk of our brains this perception
of continuity and relation between two
disconnected images is second only to
the perception of motion itself in how
fundamental it is to the very structure
of cinema
[Music]